clearly there's real anxiety uh amongst
the population both in terms of people's
household energy gas and electricity but
also uh businesses
especially smes which i am also focusing
on
the help we're putting in at the moment
the 37 billion we are part of the way
through um so the help coming in um from
october onwards um if everybody's bill
will get 400 pounds off that
in terms of
the additional
increase now
sort of deals with about half of it
but we know that's not enough
we've got to do more
uh i've been working up options the
moment i walked into this building on
the fifth of july
uh i tasked the team with two things one
let's get this 37 billion out of the
door so if you're a pensioner you get
another 300 pounds the next tranche of
the 650 pounds for the most vulnerable
households the 8 million households is
also going out but the second thing i
said was we know
and i knew then that putin will continue
to use energy as a
weapon as a way of getting back at us
for the help we're putting into ukraine
we need to remain resilient we need to
make sure that this isn't a sticking
plaster that for the long term we
continue to help the most vulnerable who
have no no cushion and that's what i'm
determined to do and we're working up
those options for both households and
for business for the incoming prime
minister on the fifth september to take
those decisions so my message today is
we'll get this 37 billion
to people's uh you know to help them for
now and then more will be coming uh
because we know this will continue in
january and of course on to april and
next year and we have to remain
resilient because the message i want to
be able to send to mr putin that the
nation wants to send is this will not
work
we will continue to face you down we'll
continue to help ukraine because you
have illegally invaded a free and
democratic country at the moment you are
leaving households
to make their effort to the war effort
as you put it alone warm words are not
going to heat homes how much money is
the government going to provide
to meet these catastrophic bill rises
for millions of people
so we're putting 37 billion now yeah
we're midway part of the way through the
scenario so based on old forecasts that
you've admitted are out of date how much
new money right so so look at let's look
at from october to december
the 400 pounds that we're providing
every household on their bills will
effectively meet about half of that
increase that was announced today
we know we need to do more because
actually the most vulnerable households
have no cushion have nothing
available to them so what i'm looking at
is how i can target that help for those
people not just to
january but we need to make sure that
we're resilient through next year so i'm
looking at all the options of how much
more i need to deliver for this
household for those smes
for making sure that we have the energy
companies so one of the things that they
said to me at the round table that we
had a few weeks ago
is the wholesale market and liquidity is
needed i'm working with the bank of
england to look at how we can provide
that liquidity because that
on its own they tell me we'll prove
we'll
push down the energy price gap by about
four to five hundred pounds so we're
looking at all those options
they'll be ready by the fifth september
for the incoming prime minister
to make uh those choices but what i
would say
to
your viewers that more help is on its
way because we know
that the most vulnerable households
need that additional help
and i'm doing the work to make sure that
that will be in place throughout next
year it's intolerable isn't it you've
seen this coming for months it is
intolerable to leave people in the dark
because of the intersecting
leadership election at a time of
national crisis people don't know they
need to know
so so look
that
sounds like
we're not
acting on this when i walked into this
building on the 5th of july
that evening i got my leadership team in
this room and said look two things one
we've got to deliver the 37 billion and
that takes operational competence we've
got to get it outdoors so the 400 pounds
off everybody's
bill uh coming in if you're a pensioner
you get 300 pounds the
second tranche of the 650 pounds for the
most vulnerable 8 million households if
you're disabled you get 150 pounds that
is has to all get out the door and then
i said equally importantly
we know this is not going to end we know
putin has now worked out that actually
this is quite a potent lever you look at
what's happening in germany and the rest
of europe we need to make sure there's
more support my preference is for it to
be targeted why because it will give us
a a
much
longer
more leeway to be able to face down
putin and send a very important message
to him that this is not going to work we
will continue to help ukraine and of
course support the most vulnerable
families in our country it's clear with
nothing new to offer
the population this morning in terms of
support people are going to have to
think about their energy use they've got
no use but to try and cut their own bill
through reducing use do you think people
should start reducing their energy use
to deal with this problem and will you
start reducing yours
so um the energy companies which we've
been working closely with these are the
people who are delivering your
electricity your gas to your home have
already started emailing and writing to
households to explain the energy price
cap in october working with them and the
regulator they're already
actually asking people if they think
they need more help that they should
contact them um
especially the most vulnerable families
in our country and we're looking at you
know what more we can do especially
those on pre-payment meters
who are really vulnerable at this period
and
the reality is that we should all look
at our energy consumption
it is a difficult time there is war on
our continent
very few people anticipated war wars
happened in far-flung places it is now
here with us we have to remain resilient
my responsibility is to deliver that
help that 400 pounds that's coming all
the other help that i've just
talked you through
but then also
equally important as i make sure there's
more help
for those families for those businesses
throughout next year because this thing
is not going away we have to continue to
support ukraine and we are determined to
face down putin and part of that is
helping those vulnerable families you
mentioned the war the foreign secretary
appears not to know whether the
president of france a nato ally is a
friend or foe is that appropriate
language for a foreign secretary let
alone a potential prime minister well it
was clearly said uh uh as a
light-hearted comment with a a you know
a touch of humor uh i think you know
it's stating the obvious that france is
one of our closest strategic allies and
defense and security of course in our
effort to face down putin uh in his
illegal um invasion of a free and
democratic country in ukraine um
the thing that i actually took away from
it and where i think liz was absolutely
right yeah we
like people to judge us on our actions
uh uh you know on our deeds not words
and i think it's right that we also hold
our allies to that very high standard do
you think do you know if he's an enemy
or a friend look it was a light-hearted
comment uh and there was lots of
chuckles around it um
you know
liz and i both know that france is a
strategic
ally in defense in
cyber in
our war you know effort in helping
ukraine
all these things um we work very closely
together but i said look
we like to be held by our allies uh on
our actions and our deeds not uh words
as we've done in in ukraine and liz has
led that effort
in facing down putin and his cronies and
sanctioning them and of course
she will continue to do that